bonsoir à tous ravi de vous retrouver
dans Ça vous regarde au sommaire ce soir
l'extrême droite face au législative
l'Union est-elle encore possible entre
Marine Le Pen et Eric Zemmour le RN
semble vouloir anéantir Éric Zemmour
mais à quel prix quant à Éric Zemmour
joue-t-il sa survie dans ce scrutin en
deuxième partie d'émission se penchera
sur le climat social en France à cet
avantage de 1er mai la retraite à 65 ans
va-t-elle mettre le feu aux poudres la
nouvelle méthode promise par Emmanuel
Macron peut-elle apaiser les esprits
autant de questions que nous poserons à
notre grand témoin ce soir Jean-Claude
Mahy ancien secrétaire général de Force
Ouvrière enfin nos affranchis on verra
avec Vincent hugost c'est faux
s'inquiéter de la situation en
Transnistrie quant à Brandon warrett il
nous rafraîchira la mémoire sur les
trois cohabitations que nous avons
connues sous la Cinquième République
voilà pour le menu c'est parti pour ça
vous regarde
[Musique]
ils ont rassemblé à eux de plus de 30%
des voix à la présidentielle ils
appartiennent à la même famille
politique mais il se livre une guerre
sans merci Marine Le Pen et Éric Zemmour
peuvent-ils encore trouver un terrain
d'entente pour les élections
législatives et bien pour en débattre
j'accueil
Erwan leker bonsoir vous êtes sociologue
polytologue et spécialiste de l'extrême
droite Frédéric Daby bonsoir directeur
général opinion de l'Ifop Richard werlib
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes un peu chez
vous sur le plateau de LCP journaliste
suisse alors vous êtes un peu en
transhuman si on va dire entre
c'est le passe de l'alpage le temps un
alpage alémanique le quotidien suisse
Blic voilà et puis Alexandre suzer nous
rejoindra dans un instant journaliste au
Parisien qui a suivi les campagnes
d'Eric Zemmour et de Marine Le Pen et
pour commencer roulement de tambour pour
Stéphane blackowski
[Musique]
bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Comment bonsoir
à tous Alors si j'ai bien compris
Stéphane j'ai bien compris on va finir
par douter de l'intelligence de Rick
Zemmour c'est quand même une qualité
qu'on était à peu près tous près à lui
accorder et puis là il y a comme un
doute bien que le fait que par orgueil
se laisser aveugler au point d'aller
insulter la personne dont on a
absolument besoin pour les législatives
au minimum il y a un petit défaut de
sens politique on l'écoute
hélas
hélas hélas c'est la huitième fois que
la défaite frappe le nom de Le Pen
je voyais cette défaite venir depuis des
années et ce n'est vraiment pas de
gaieté de cœur que je l'annonçais alors
ça c'était le soir du second tour mais
depuis il a quand même mis de l'eau dans
son vin alors je rappelle les choses
dans l'ordre il faut réfléchir avant
d'agir passer c'est vraiment trop tard
là pour par exemple il vient de
découvrir apparemment Eric
marine moi je dirige comme ça monsieur
dans toutes les circonscriptions de
France le RN est devant reconquête
c'est-à-dire que il est même pas sûr
d'être élu député d'autant plus que le
RN après mis de présenter un candidat
contre lui donc évidemment comme vous
dites de l'eau dans son vin mais
qu'est-ce qu'il fait il promet de ne pas
mettre de candidats en face de ceux qui
considèrent comme ces alliés regarder il
a fait la liste donc pour lui ses alliés
ça va donc de cioti a Dupont-Aignan en
passant par Marine Le Pen c'est la
fameuse union des droites si chères à
Éric Zemmour exactement vous savez que
Marion maréchal a une théorie là-dessus
elle explique qu'en fait Marine Le Pen
n'arrivera jamais pouvoir si elle
s'applique uniquement sur le vote
populaire il faut que sociologiquement
elle s'élargissent vers les classes un
peu plus aisée explication que Marine Le
Pen fait des scores absolument inédits
je vous donne un exemple dans une région
je connais bien en provençale-côte
d'Azur dans des villes disons le plus
aisées qui n'étaient pas initialement
des villes dans lequel elle faisait des
sports importants qui sont précisément
les villes où Éric Zemmour a su parler à
cette électorat sociologiquement
issus plutôt des classes moyennes ou
supérieurs sauf Queen cette histoire
d’union des droites ça n'emballe pas
grand monde puisque officiellement on
n'est pas de droite au RN donc au
contraire on est un peu comme miam de
Macron on dépasse ce clivage droit de
gauche donc explication de Sébastien
Chenu
des droites enfin je veux dire ça a été
le débat du premier tour
Eric Zemmour est pour l'Union des
droites nous on est pour une grande
réunion patriote qui dépasse la gauche
et à droite parce que c'est concept de
gauche à droite ne fonctionne pas alors
ça c'est la querelle stratégique mais il
y a aussi des querelles de personnes un
peu mais ça arrive quand on
occupe le même espace politique c'est
c'est ils sont un peu voisins la peine
et Zemmour et je sais pas si vous
connaissez les chiffres mais regardez à
Paris on en est un crime sur trois à
Paris et Dieu décrire les voisinage donc
c'est sûr que entre Le Pen et Zemmour
voyez c'est tendu on est quand même pas
à parler de crime là mais plutôt
symbolique mais imaginez qu'il y a une
alliance entre reconquête et le RN
évidemment que Marine Le Pen serait
tenté de demander la tête des traîtres
ceux qui pendant la campagne ont quitté
le RN pour aller rejoindre Zemmour donc
forcément ceux qui sont concernés
Nicolas best Stéphane Ravier leur
aliment c'est un peu leur arène mort
donc hier soir le sénateur ravier vous
êtes son mieux pour torpiller cet
éventuer l'accord en écoute être avec
elle n'est pas suffisant il faut être
comme elle donc si vous n'êtes pas comme
elle et bien elle refuse tout accord
tout alliances parce qu'elle n'est pas
dans la même démarche qu'Eric Zemmour
qui lui il veut sauver la France et elle
veut sauver son parti oui on a la droite
nationale les réunions copropriété sont
assez on a du mal à est-ce qu'il
pourrait pas quand même y avoir des des
alliances au cas par cas oui si Marine
Le Pen était du genre à tendre la joue
droite contre le gifle la joue gauche
c'est pas sûr que ça soit le cas plutôt
œil pour œil dent pour dent Zemmour lui
a piqué des cadres et ben maintenant
pour les législatives c'est son tour il
n'y a pas que Marine Jordan Bardella 26
ans seulement alors il a voulu parler
d'avenir c'est pas seulement
législatives l'avenir l'union avec la
droite ça va plus loin que ça
l'après Macron se fera autour du
rassemblement national et nous allons
continuer de nous élargir nous allons
continuer de travailler avec des gens
mais il a des gens très talentueux
autour de lui je pense pas en face
Stanislas Rigot avec qui moi je pourrais
parfaitement travailler à l'avenir donc
Stanislas Rego 23 ans porte-parole de
Zemmour gendarmes Bardella 26 ans vous
voyez que eux ils sont évidemment quand
on te parle d'union ça va arriver un
jour merci beaucoup Stéphane blackovski
pour ce panorama complet de la situation
sur cette partie de l'échiquier
politique
Erwan Le Coeur est-ce qu'il a commis une
faute politique
Eric Zemmour le soir du second tour en
attaquant Marine Le Pen comme il l'a
fait alors d'une part je dirais que la
faute politique et la faute sociologique
date de il y a plus de six mois ce n'est
pas le soir du premier tour ou du
deuxième tour c'est depuis le début le
zemourisme était est une bulle
médiatique alimentée financée par le
groupe Bolloré mais sociologiquement
l'affaire maigrir l'avait déjà démontré
il n'y a pas de sociologie politique
suffisante pour à la droite de la droite
donc à l'extrême droite pure et dure tel
que Jean-Marie Le Pen avait eu un
premier électorat dans les années 80 il
n'y a pas assez pour évidemment pas pour
gagner une présidentielle il l'a
démontré 7% lui donnait 15 dans les
sondages parce que les sondeurs sont
très parisiens et lui aussi et puis
c'est pas sérieux de dire
par là c'est que du mois de novembre ne
sont pas le résultat du mois d'avril
c'est tout à fait normal
était celui qui a été décrit par des
sondages il y a eu une bulle médiatique
qui n'est pas en accord avec l'état de
l'opinion des Français sur tout un tas
d'autres sujets que ceux dont parle
monsieur Zemmour c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
si on ne parle que de l'Immigration et
de l'Islam alors monsieur Zemmour et eau
dans les sondages si on parle de tous
les autres sujets qui concernent les
Français monsieur Zemmour est très bas
dans les sondages donc ce qui s'est
passé au moment de la présidentielle
c'est qu'on a pas parlé tout le temps
que de ce que monsieur Zemmour voulait
entendre et deuxième élément là pour les
législatives c'est encore pire c'est à
dire que législatives c'est une élection
particulière ça n'a rien à voir avec la
présidentielle c'est à chaque fois une
petite présidentielle dans un endroit où
les gens sont connus ou pas connus et ou
en gros il faut des alliances de
deuxième tour pour pouvoir gagner
monsieur Zemmour peut faire alliance
avec qui en gros il a on vient
l'expliqué il a été très méchant avec
les gens du rassemblement national et
Marine Le Pen il a fait une erreur là
pour le coup médiatique parce que en
effet je pense que c'est son c'est son
sur moi qui ne fonctionne pas il a un
ego surdimensionné et donc quand il
pense qu'il a raison sur quelque chose
il le dit haut et fort et donc il pense
qu'il était très malin de rappeler que
avec Le Pen on ne gagne jamais c'est
exactement ce qui avait fait Bruno
Maigret en 1998 on a vu la fin de Bruno
megra ensuite Richard Berli observateur
vraiment de la vie politique française
comment vous vous l'interprétez là cette
sorte de déclaration kamikaze d'Éric
Zemmour au soir du second tour mais je
pense qu'il y a quand même une part qui
est liée à la succession de Marine Le
Pen c'est-à-dire il pensait que le RN
était prêt à tourner la page de Marine
Le Pen et à choisir un autre dirigeants
de pousser Marine Le Pen dans le fossé
pour dire les choses comme elles sont il
veut à tout prix jouer les premiers
rôles dans dans les années qui venaient
qui viennent et donc le meilleur moyen
pour lui peut-être un peu caricatural et
peut-être complètement je dirais qui va
s'avérer complètement faux et équival
lui coûter cher c'est que il veut tout
de suite l'associer à l'échec il alors
que Marine Le Pen alors que quand même
la plupart des commentateurs français à
mon avis d'ailleurs de manière un peu
surprenante ont insisté sur la victoire
entre guillemets de Marine Le Pen du
fait de ses 42 % malgré sa défaite
présidentielle lui il dit le contraire
il dit en fait c'est une défaite et le
clan Le Pen et est condamné à la défaite
donc je pense qu'il fait passer l'idée
de sa succession devant la réalité
électorale alors l'avenir dira si c'est
juste ou faux mais en tout cas c'est
très clair en gros c'est lui le sauveur
de ce camp nationaliste il me semble pas
que c'est l'opinion que les Français en
ont vraiment alors Alexandre suzer nous
a rejoint du journaliste au Parisien
bonsoir est-ce que vous pensez qu'elle
aurait pu avoir lieu cette union entre
reconquête et le rassemblement national
sans cette déclaration de d'Éric Zemmour
où est-ce que c'était
c'était mort d'avance je pense que cette
déclaration tombe bien quand même pour
le rassemblement national c'est le
prétexte idéal pour ne pas prendre la
main ou la
saisir la main tendue parce qu'il a
quand même tendu la main juste après
donc de toute façon c'était très
paradoxal mais effectivement je pense
pas que le RN avait 13 ans envie de
toute façon de répondre à ça cet appel
pour deux raisons des raisons un petit
peu déjà humaines un peu subjectives
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de haine
recuites ça fait quand même des mois que
reconquête a essayé de tuer le
rassemblement national de le grand
remplacer en quelque sorte et donc ils
avaient ils ont quand même envie ils ont
aucune raison de vouloir le sauver et
puis par ailleurs il y a la réalité
évidemment électorale qui est que le
rassemblement national n'a pas besoin
véritablement de reconquête alors que a
besoin de rapport de manche du
rassemblement national donc le rapport
de force ne plaisait pas dans ce sens
d'un mot ça fait grincer des dents au
sein de reconquête cette déclaration
d'Eric Zemmour c'est oui certains alors
évidemment sous couvert d'anonymat
certains
extrêmement maladroit effectivement
c'est complètement incontres sens de
l'appel à l'union des droites qu'il
était censé incarner et qu'il rappelait
à nouveau ce dimanche soir Frédéric Daby
est-ce qu'il existe des passerelles
entre les électorats de Marine Le Pen et
Derrick Zemmour vous avez quelques
quelques chiffres à nous donner par
rapport aux électorats extrêmement
différents c'est vrai que cette
déclaration d'Eric Zemmour moi ne m'a
pas surprise elle a été en continuité
vous l'avez dit avoir une Locker avec
toute sa campagne électorale qui était
le vote le Bad est à votre inutile car
elle va perdre contre elle Macron et
notamment il y avait un moment
cathartique c'est ce débat où elle sera
encore plus nul quand 2017 c'est ça qui
était au cœur de son discours donc
c'était difficile pour lui à 20h même si
l'imaginait que Marine Le Pen perd et
qu'il y avait ces élections législatives
après de changer de pied maintenant
c'est vrai que Marine Le Pen entre les
deux tours n'a fait aucun signe vers
l'électorat Zemmour est-ce que vous avez
besoin non dans notre rolling of
Fiducial elle passe de 80 85 % de
reports d'électeurs 0 vers elle à 75 77%
à un petit des portes peut-être
justement du fait du débat ou des
électeurs Zemmour convaincus on dit non
décidément elle n'a pas la carrure
présidentielle en tout cas on avait un
électorat Zemmour alors au moment où il
était plutôt à niveau élevé et je ne
pense pas que ce soit seulement une
bulle médiatique qui incarnait une
nouveauté une radicalité et puis c'était
Cassandre il avait raison sur le déclin
sur la situation du pays il avait la
chance d'avoir deux sources électorales
c'est à dire qu'il prenait au plus haut
un tiers de l'électorat Le Pen 2017 d'où
le niveau de Marine Le Pen
particulièrement bas avant sa dynamique
de fin de campagne il arrivait à prendre
20 25% de l'électorafillon ça va être de
ce point de vue là si Éric Zemmour
incarnait se rapprochement des droites
avec un échec quand même il a jamais
réussi à percer dans l'électorat
populaire de Marine Le Pen un
électoratrice
puis chez Emmanuel Macron on est quand
même finalement sur des électorat
relativement différents mais
complémentaires d'une certaine façon il
est fort dans les grandes villes et chez
les populations aisées elle est fort
dans les villes moyennes à la campagne
un électorat je suis d'accord
complémentaire mais il faut pas oublier
que cette élector Azemmour c'est
complicidérablement réduit pour ne pas
dire effondré on n'a pas parlé de
l'Ukraine pour lui il y a un avant et un
après Ukraine ou justement après ces
erreurs d'après ce sont sur l'Ukraine
les Français et les électeurs potentiels
découvrent que découvre que que comment
dire Cassandre s'est trompé justement
sur le Kawan le cœur cette
complémentarité des électorats ça peut
pas intéresser le rassemblement national
quand même oui ça pourrait et c'est bien
ce que dit d'ailleurs Jordan Bardella il
dit comme dans les années 80 je rappelle
la fin des années 80 il y a des accords
à l'époque entre la droite de droite et
le rassemblement le Front national de
l'époque sur un certain nombre de
circonscriptions notamment dans le
Sud-Est en effet la droite a besoin des
voies du Front national de l'époque pour
être élu au deuxième tour et le Front
national de l'époque espère qu'il va
avoir une contrepartie il ne l'aura pas
à l'époque dans la fin des années 80
parce que Jean-Marie Le Pen ne le veut
pas forcément il ne veut pas qu'il y ait
des gens au sein de son parti qui soit
plus puissants que lui qui soit député
alors que lui ne le serait et d'ailleurs
même le maire de Toulon finira par ne
plus l'être le maire de Toulon donc il y
a quelque chose à l'époque de je dirais
Jean-Marie Le Pen ne voulait pas
forcément gagner mais il y a eu des
accords et Jordan Bardella ce qu'il dit
c'est clair c'est il n'y aura pas
d'accord d'appareils au premier tour
parce qu'on préférait que Zemmour
s'effondre et puis au deuxième tour on
verra si l'un ou l'autre on peut les
sauver il cite l'une ou l'autre des
personnalités au sein de génération Z
par exemple pour dire toi je veux bien
que tu viennes mais c'est une façon
comme une autre de en gros de faire
exactement c'est
la Marine Le Pen exactement
idéologiquement proche de Zemmour qui
sont pas trop mauvaises dans les médias
et puis on va préparer l'avenir ensemble
puis Zemmour on va le laisser
s'effondrer je le dis ça a été dit un
petit peu cette famille politique on le
on l'oublie souvent c'est la plus dure
c'est celle où il n'y a aucune il n'y a
pas de quartier quand malheur au vaincu
c'est vraiment
bégrer a dû quitter la politique il
avait un contrat sur la tête il prenait
des des un service d'ordre professionnel
professionnel parce que dans cette
famille politique ça ne rigole pas c'est
à dire que il y a eu des morts il y a eu
des gens qui ont rencontré des arbres
comme ce sirbois il y a eu des gens
comme ça on parle bien de l'extrême
droite on parle pas de la gauche
tranquille ou de Emmanuel Macron
Alexandre suzer oui d'accord de
désistement au second tour mais en fait
on voit pas très bien ce que ça recouvre
parce qu'il n'y aura aucune
circonscription sauf enfin vraiment
aucune raison qui est des
circonscriptions dans laquelle la
question se pose ça c'est il y a un
chiffre en fait à propos de ça alors
évidemment c'est c'est pas scientifique
on s'appuie sur le premier tour de la
présidentielle les scores de Marine Le
Pen et Éric Zemmour et en fait dans 421
circonscriptions elle pourrait maintenir
ses candidats au second tour
Eric Zemmour dans deux circonscriptions
Éric Zemmour dans 0 sa conception alors
dans trois circonscriptions si on compte
la 8e des Français de l'étranger sur 577
donc personne n'atteint les 12,5% des
inscrits et donc les deux
pour être qualifier si on fait des
projections et donc théoriquement même
si c'est comme vous l'avez dit pas très
scientifique
il pourrait se qualifier au troisième
maison du coup des accords de
désistement ça n'a aucun sens et j'en
parlais en Corse-Matin avec un gradé du
rassemblement national qui qui rigolait
qui effectivement on est on se fout de
leur gueule ils le disait comme ça en
fait vraiment on se retrouve avec avec
et si on Frédéric Davis si on parle de
de Marine Le Pen du rassemblement
national elle peut tabler sur combien de
députés au législatives alors de la même
manière que vous avez parlé de choses
peu scientifiques c'est très compliqué
d'avoir de faire des projections sur une
législative ça prend pas en compte
l'histoire des circonscriptions le poids
des députés sortants Marine Le Pen
arrive en tête au second tour donc elle
dépasse 50% dans 158 circonscriptions
c'est un chiffre important supérieur
bien sûr à ce qu'elle avait eu en 2017
mais clairement on sait très bien que
contenu des règles des élections
législatives c'est à dire 12 et demi
pour cent des inscrits pour soutenir il
y aura peu de triangulaires qui est
toujours le la meilleure configuration
pour que le RN gagne tel ou tel
circonscription rappelle juste la règle
vous l'avez évoqué d'un mot mais inscrit
c'est à dire que si les deux premiers
sont qualifiés pour que le troisième se
qualifié si à 50 % d'abstention je
prends l'hypothèse de 2017 faut faire 25
% donc ça sera des cas extrêmement rares
il y en a eu une je crois en 2017
en tout cas très peu je dirais une ou
deux en 2017 à la différence de 97 qui
est la dernière ils sont législative si
je puis dire autonome et déconnecté du
scrutin présidentiel mais il y a aussi
un cas la configuration de duel de
second tour et la pire pour le front ou
le rassemblement national entre 1988
victoires de la députée Yann Pia dans le
Var et 2017 victoire de Marine Le Pen de
Gilbert Cola de d'autres députés RN
pendant 30 ans le r&fn n'a jamais gagné
un duel de second tour la logique
d'élimination tout sauf le RN marche
quand même dans ses circonscriptions
c'est que j'ai l'impression que il
cherche aussi à rallumer la flamme
médiatique parce que c'est le flamme
médiatique elle est en train de
s'éteindre le score de Marine Le Pen a
en quelque sorte été j'allais dire le le
tonneau d'eau qui est tombé sur cette
flamme médiatique parce que maintenant
elle est redevenue la patronne
incontestée de ce grand politique le
suffrage universel lui a donné raison et
on va voir les médias sans doute à mon
avis beaucoup moins sensibles au désirez
bien une bulle médiatique comme le
disait une bulle je sais pas mais en
tout cas il y a eu moi je suis persuadé
qu'il y a une aspiration il y a une
dynamique médiatique très forte et donc
je j'ai l'impression qu'avec Zemmour et
c'est de la relancer c'est le flamme
médiatique en disant c'est moi le
recours à la fin et ça il est possible
que sa voix tombe dans le silence on va
s'intéresser à présent aux électeurs de
Marine Le Pen dans la deuxième
circonscription de l'Oise où elle a
devancé Emmanuel Macron au second tour
alors qu'est-ce qu'il y a motivé le
choix de ses électeurs le vote Le Pen
est-il encore votre majoritairement
protestataire les osseux et Antoine
Coutin se sont rendus à Auneuil près de
Beauvais dans l'Oise
Auneuil village de 2800 habitants qui le
24 avril dernier ont exprimé dans les
urnes un air de défiance
n'est plus le même depuis le résultat de
la présidentielle ici la candidat du
Rassemblement national fait la course en
tête
57,7% des suffrages dans la deuxième
circonscription de l'Oise au second tour
de la présidentielle en 2017 au
législatives le jeune candidat Gaëtan du
cisaille parachuté par le RN avait
nettement perdu avec 45% des suffrages
dans un duel de second tour contre la
marcheuse agnestyle aujourd'hui
udi qui envisage de se représenter le
match retour en juin pourrait bien
ressembler à une revanche avec comme
tête d'affiche pour le rassemblement
national l'ancien journaliste Philippe
Balard quand on voit les scores du
deuxième tour de Marine Le Pen du
premier d'ailleurs et du deuxième tour
quand on voit cette progression qui
gagne la France notamment dans les zones
rurales dans les zones périurbaines
autrement dit dans la France qui souffre
on a de très très bons espoirs ici on
l'observe la colère sur fond de crise du
pouvoir d'achat pourrait bien faire le
jeu du rassemblement national
pas pu le gasoil c'est pareil
non c'est plus possible quoi il y a de
plus en plus de Français il s'en
aperçoit très bien à force de continuer
comme ça tôt ou tard un jour elle finira
par passer c'est surtout le pouvoir
d'achat le pouvoir d'achat parce que
nous retraités ça fait moi je suis
retraité depuis 12 ans le pouvoir
d'achat on n'a jamais été j'ai pas été
remonter depuis 12 ans des craintes
nombreuses et un objectif pour beaucoup
ici offrir à Marine Le Pen le moyen de
peser à l'Assemblée nationale
Frédéric Davy a une expression qui m'a
interpellé dans ce reportage c'est ce
vote barrage dans la bouche d'un
électeur de Marine Le Pen barrage à
Emmanuel Macron ça c'est quoi c'est
l'équivalent d'un vote anti-système
c'est quoi clairement c'est un vote anti
Macron tout sauf Macron qui s'épouse
structuré pendant la campagne parce
qu'il y avait l'Ukraine parce qu'il y
avait l'effet drapeau il y avait la
logique de continuité qui a pas pris qui
a profité à Emmanuel Macron mais pour le
jour du vote on a posé avec if of
Fiducial une question sur la
signification du vote on voit qu'une
majorité des lecteurs de Marine Le Pen
ont voté pour elle par conviction pour
qu'elle soit élue présidente de la
République puisque pour faire barrage à
Emmanuel Macron mais de l'ordre de 55 45
donc c'est votre barrage et ça c'est
nouveau à une à une époque et je passe
votre contrôle ont été sous un sur un
électorat extrêmement protestataire
c'est venu de la jeunesse la majorité
des électeurs de Marine Le Pen jeune
notamment des rinnovottants ont voté par
adhésion il y a pas la mémoires du Front
national d'avant etc et de la même
manière et là ça nuance un peu ce qu'on
peut affirmer des insoumis au lendemain
du vote sur un président
élu une majorité assez nette des
lecteurs de second tour d'Emmanuel
Macron de l'ordre de 58% ont voté pour
le président sortant pour qu'il soit
réélu plus que pour faire barrage à
Marine Le Pen bien sûr dans l'électorat
Mélenchon c'est cette dimension de
barrage qui a été majoritaire autre
question on n'entend pas parler
d'immigration ou de sécurité dans la
bouche de ces électeurs du RN pourquoi
parce que ils osent pas en parler face
caméra ou c'est passé derrière d'autres
préoccupations pour la première fois
dans une élection présidentielle lui
avait un candidat à une candidate fnrn
la première motivation de vote n'a pas
été le diptyque insécurité immigration
ça a été le pouvoir d'achat et là votre
micro-trottoir est absolument alors le
micro-trottoirs de Marine Le Pen mais
c'est vrai que c'est c'est une c'est une
c'est une thématique on l'a vu sur le
terrain qui est absolument tout écraser
en revanche dans l'électorat d'Éric
Zemmour de premier tour on a retrouvé ce
type immigration insécurité cette
thématique n'ont pas disparu loin de là
mais elles ont été reléguées derrière
les fins de mois c'est quelque chose que
vous constatez vous aussi
le temps que sociologue quand vous allez
voir un peu cet électorat oui bien sûr
quand on fait des groupes qualitatifs
quand on fait quand on regarde un petit
peu les enquêtes sur le long terme sur
les valeurs des Français tous les 10 ans
tout un tas d'études comme ça sur 10000
personnes on voit bien qu'il y a
clairement un clivage de plus en plus
fort non plus gauche droite mais sur ce
qu'on a appelé cette tripolarisation du
champ politique dans la dans laquelle on
a donc ce camp qu'on va appeler
conservateur de droite nationale
populiste avec Marine Le Pen et
identitaire avec bien sûr monsieur
Zemmour et là on voit bien que dans ce
camp là les gens et notamment Marine Le
Pen a bénéficié de l'effet Zemmour
puisqu'elle n'avait plus à rappeler des
choses qui étaient dans son héritage
dans son ADN elle est une Le Pen elle a
pas besoin de rappeler que son père
disait cela il y a 20 ans 30 ans 50 ans
je rappelle 72 ça fait 50 ans que le
Front National et Le Pen est sur le
devant de la scène donc elle n'avait pas
besoin de rappeler tout ça l'immigration
la sécurité de l'islam tout le monde
savait qu'elle était la candidate de
cela donc elle a bien joué en effet très
clairement sur sécurité pouvoir d'achat
protection de l'État et elle a sur le
thème c'est moi la leader de ce camp là
Eric Zemmour est un est un feu follet
est un feu de paille et c'est moi la
leader et aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit dans
des endroits comme celui où vous avez
fait votre reportage dans le Nord dans
le Pas-de-Calais dans dans la Creuse et
dans tout un tas d'endroit et même en
Dordogne désormais c'est des gens qui
disent et vous l'avez vu en Guadeloupe
Martinique premier tour c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui arrive en tête deuxième
tour c'est Marine Le Pen qui écrase tout
donc en fait il y a eu un vote anti
Macron très fort et j'irai même jusqu'à
dire c'est assez étonnant mais fallait
que d'abîme contredirea peut-être au
premier tour Jean-Luc Mélenchon à 40 %
de vote pour lui qui vient en vote utile
qui ne vote pas pour Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui vote pour qu'il soit éventuellement
en deuxième tour 40 % de son électorat
60 %
pour lui 40% pas pour lui et au deuxième
tour Marine Le Pen Emmanuel Macron ont
le même phénomène 60% de leur électorat
vote pour eux et 40% votre contre
l'autre vous imaginez bien que si on
parle des législatives cette électorat
de votre contre l'autre il va être
beaucoup moins mobilisé et on aura en
effet 50 à 60% d'abstention beaucoup
chez les classes populaires beaucoup
chez les jeunes c'est à dire que et
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et Marine Le Pen ont
un problème pour les législatives on
avait vu en 2017 ils avaient perdu entre
45 et 50% de leur potentiel de la
présidentielle aux législative et du
coup les personnes âgées qui ont
beaucoup voté Macron vous me dites si
c'est pas vrai 70% des plus 70 ans
facile à retenir 60 % les plus de 60 ans
70% des plus de 70 ans on est quasiment
chez Sarkozy 2017 qui se mobilisent très
fortement si en plus on leur dit on vous
met la retraite à 65 ans vous savez
pourquoi pour payer votre dépendance ils
vont se mobiliser
on en parlera dans la deuxième partie de
l'émission si vous voulez Alexandre
suzer vous vous constatez vous aussi ce
vote utile dans l'extrême droite dans
l'électorat de l'extrême droite vous
avez fait plein de meeting pendant cette
campagne vous avez parlé un peu aux
électeurs alors ceux qui se plaisent
dans les meetings sont plutôt quand même
les plus convertis donc c'est pas
forcément ceux qui votent par de façon
stratégique c'est plus des convaincu
mais effectivement Marine Le Pen dans
l'entre-deux-tours a explicitement qu'il
fallait faire barrage c'est vraiment son
expression qu'elle est utilisée faire
barrage à Emmanuel Macron c'est vraiment
le rejet du président qui avait un bilan
contrairement à 5 ans sur lequel elle a
énormément misé ça c'est une évidence
mais effectivement le l'abstention et la
sociologie des lectorat au législatif
fait que les projections assez
optimistes pour elle pour législatives
seront sans doute très décevante malgré
tout pour Marine Le Pen si on parle
justement de ce scrutin des législatives
mais du côté d'Éric Zemmour il est quand
même entouré de plusieurs têtes
d'affiches Marion maréchal Nicolas Bay
et Jérôme rivière qui ont quitté le
rassemblement national pour reconquête
il y a Guillaume Peltier mais pour
l'instant aucun n'est officiellement
candidat au législative est-ce qu'ils
vont se présenter pour l'instant aucun
lait et rien n'indique qu'il le soit
pourquoi ils ont peur d'une trop lourde
défaite Gilbert Collard Nicolas Bey
Jérôme rivière ont des mandats au
Parlement européen ils ont aucune raison
de l'équité c'est des mandats qui les
qui qui sont intéressants pour eux ils
se sont ils les ont contrairement à des
mandats beaucoup plus hypothétiques s'il
concourrait au législatives
Eric Zemmour pareil à partir du moment
où il n'a pas de perspective de victoire
ça serait catastrophique pour lui de
alors qu'il débute finalement sa
carrière politique de se représenter une
seconde fois et d'aller directement un
deuxième échec donc c'est extrêmement
périlleux pour lui donc vous pensez
qu'il ne se présentera pas au
législatives je pense qu'il se
présentera pas les châtives et ça sera
d'ailleurs pareil pour Marion maréchal
qui est à elle en plus un prétexte
parfait puisqu'elle est enceinte et donc
elle peut mettre en avant évidemment des
aléas personnels ce qui pose évidemment
un problème dans des parties nous on le
on le voit vous savez en Suisse régime
parlementaire ou l'extrême droite fait
30% de l'électorat en gros depuis un peu
près une vingtaine d'années ce sont
quand même des parties qui sont
extrêmement liées à la figure du chef si
le chef n'est pas là au combat électoral
le parti tout de suite on voit le score
BC et une chose qui me frappe c'est
j'allais dire l'intelligence électorale
des Français et le syndrome de
compétences on attribue la compétence
présidentielle à Emmanuel Macron
semble-t-il parce qu'il a été élu et
dans le camp de la droite dure on ATT la
compétence pouvoir d'achat Marine Le Pen
Eric Zemmour n'est pas jugé crédible
pour défendre le pouvoir d'achat des
Français donc ce critère de compétence
finalement qui qui défavorise Marine Le
Pen face à Emmanuel Macron elle me
semble le favoriser face à Éric Zemmour
est-ce que vous pensez Richard Vallet
que
Eric Zemmour peut être tenté par la
politique de la terre brûlée
c'est-à-dire que finalement ce sont
principales atout c'est sa capacité de
nuisance
en imposant des candidats reconquête
dans toutes les circonscriptions face
aux rassemblement national
la loi sur le financement des parties
c'est intéressant un euro 50 par voie
dès l'erreur qu'on a 1% des c'est un
aspect que j'avais pas que j'avais pas
en tête moi il me semble quand même
qu'il est dans une lutte politique pour
occuper une place pour occuper une place
dans le champ politique qui soit une
place entre guillemets positive pour lui
il veut être associé à un combat donc je
sais pas j'ai un petit peu de peine à
penser qu'il devienne au fond le le
baron trait noir de la politique
Erwan Lecoeur sur cet aspect financier
parce que en fait le financement des
partis politiques se joue au
législatives c'est important pour
reconquête selon vous parce que ça veut
dire que pendant 5 ans ce qu'ils vont
toucher de l'État va dépendre de ce
qu'ils vont faire au législatives le
problème c'est que reconquête est un
parti que j'apparais de nouvelles
génération c'est un parti 2.0 c'est un
parti médiatique c'est un parti qui d'un
seul coup nous a annoncé qu'il avait des
dizaines de milliers d'adhérents qui
étaient arrivés d'un seul coup comme
cela le Front National qui avait été
longtemps le parti le plus important de
France avant la scission notamment avec
Maigret semble être devenu un parti
moyen avec des cadres intermédiaires qui
s'en vont qui sont déçus au moment des
élections intermédiaires le problème des
Zemmour c'est qu'en fait il a créé un
parti par le haut comme ça vient d'être
dit entièrement par la tête si lui ne va
pas au législatif si d'une certaine
façon s'il devient un polémiste de
plateau financé par Monsieur Bolloré il
a ni besoin la partie ni besoin d'argent
il a juste besoin d'un salaire il a déjà
une maison d'édition sa vie ça va enfin
j'ai envie de dire moi je vois pas très
bien l'intérêt qu'il aurait à créer un
parti alors que objectivement il va y
avoir une guerre de clerc pour le
leadership dans ce bloc politique et
dans la guerre telle qu'elle est engagée
aujourd'hui il a il a il a peu de chance
de gagner si Marine Le Pen n'avait pas
la possibilité je rappelle elle a plus
de 10 ans moins que lui quand même donc
si on veut regarder de ce côté là elle
n'a que 53 ans elle reste une femme
politique entre guillemets jeune an etc
mais très jeune elle est encore plutôt
la pêche laniaque elle a envie voilà
quand on voit son père qui qui est
encore en vie on se dit que dans la
famille ça va il y a pas de il y a pas
de problème de gêne et elle avait Marion
maréchal qui était problématique
maintenant elle a trouvé dans le clan le
successeur et donc j'ai envie de dire le
clan Le Pen à régler son problème de
succession c'est Jordan Bardella le
genre et donc ni Zemmour ni Marion n'ont
intérêt à faire de vieux-zo dans les
environs parce que je vous le rappelle
ça peut aller très vite très fort
Alexandre suzer il a les moyens Éric
Zemmour de présenter des candidats dans
toutes les circonscriptions aujourd'hui
ils disent qu'effectivement ils ont les
577 candidats
on peut penser il a il a créé
effectivement de l'enthousiasme on va
pas se mentir auprès même si c'est une
fraction très minoritaire de l'opinion
c'est quelqu'un de très clivant qui
suscite autant du rejet que de
l'adhésion auprès de sa sympathisants
donc il a aujourd'hui environ plus de
100000 adhérents donc je pense que si il
fallait trouver des candidats il est en
mesure de le faire le problème encore
une fois c'est de les faire élire donc
il a tout intérêt quand même je pense en
présenter un maximum non pas avec
l'objectif d'avoir des députés en nombre
ni même un groupe c'est même pas la
peine d'y penser en revanche pour
essayer de faire trébucher effectivement
Marine Le Pen on peut trouver ça pas
très constructif mais ce qui se joue
derrière c'est comme comme on disait
tout à l'heure le leadership de la
famille politique plus Marine Le Pen
sera affaibli si elle est dans
l'incapacité à nouveau à avoir un groupe
à l'Assemblée nationale il pourra
essayer de refaire son couplet sur le
fait que encore une fois Marine Le Pen
n'a pas les moyens de ses ambitions et
que lui est là pour assurer le relève
mais le problème c'est que la
perspective est quand même très
lointaine cinq ans après cet échec et
sans représentation Assemblée nationale
ça va être extrêmement difficile avec en
plus un cycle électoral extrêmement
faible puisque 2000 sauf référendum sauf
l'élection qui nous échapperait mais
2024 élections européennes pas
d'élection en 2023 et en 2025 des
simples municipales ou c'est très dur de
s'implanter en 2026 c'est une longue
traversée du désert après les élections
législatives pour les parties battues
c'est vrai que le pouvoir de nuisances
d'Eric Zemmour quand on voit le rapport
de force présidentielle Le Pen Zemmour
et va être relativement limité mais
c'est vrai qu'il ne peut pas ne pas
présenter beaucoup de candidats puisque
pendant toute la campagne il y a eu un
doute sur qui il était est-ce que c'est
un polémique est-ce que c'est un homme
politique est-ce qu'il arrive dans la
durée donc s'inscrire dans la durée sans
candidat c'est quand même compliqué
quand même beaucoup de candidats mais la
question comme que vous êtes tous
soulevé sur sur l'incarnation sur qui va
mener cette bataille ça pose un vrai
problème avec une base en plus assez
assez comment dire mobilisé militante il
a quand même réussi à lever une centaine
de milliers de militants c'est
particulièrement d'adhérent c'est
particulièrement impressionnant pour un
parti si jeune un parti où l'adhésion
n'est pas une adhésion en marche une
émission d'un cric mais une adhésion
payante un petit tour de table pour
clore le débat
Eric Zemmour est-il politiquement mort
aujourd'hui selon vous est-ce qu'il a de
l'avenir en fait il est en étau entre
une droite à qui il a pris beaucoup de
ses électeurs parce qu'on l'a dit il n'a
pas pris tant que ça à Marine Le Pen il
a pris beaucoup à Heller et d'ailleurs
Valérie Pécresse on a on a subi les
conséquences si elle a l'air décidé de
mettre quelqu'un d'autre comme à Laurent
Wauquiez ou quelques autres à la tête de
leur parties
ery Zemmour est en difficulté extrême
parce que pour le coup alors évoqué
beaucoup plus crédible à tout point de
vue pour incarner une droite de droite
que Éric Zemmour qui n'a pas fait montre
d'une grande intelligence stratégique
jusqu'à maintenant et qui reste un bon
polémiste médiatiquement intéressant
rigolo et bien embauché par Bolloré
enfin on se fait pas embaucher par les
électeurs comment se fait embaucher par
Vincent Bolloré c'est pas exactement le
même le même genre d'élection on va dire
donc si la droite décide de jouer contre
Zemmour et que Marine Le Pen on l'a vu
va jouer contre Zemmour son avenir
politique est quand même très très mis
en péril dans mon très rapidement je
pense une porte ouverte en disant qu'on
politique on n'est jamais on n'est
jamais mort effectivement évidemment
n'est pas mort mais effectivement les
perspectives sont quand même très
difficile pour toutes les raisons qu'on
a évoqué et sa radicalité enfin de
campagne notamment qui a été mise en
beaucoup il y a beaucoup accentué sur sa
radicalite en fin de campagne laisse
penser plutôt un destin à la bonne
omégaie en réalité certains même en
interne font le parallèle en disant
attention on est en train de devenir le
MMR Richard Wery tout de suite alors moi
je pense pas du tout ça je pense que il
a un avenir il a un avenir parce qu'il a
une caractéristique Éric Zemmour c'est
que c'est vraiment un homme de son
époque et il peut il sait attraper les
bons moments et donc si l'histoire qui
va venir qui va se faire y compris
d'ailleurs sur la scène internationale
s'il y a un moment donné une bouffée
d'air je pense notamment au retour de
Trump aux États-Unis par exemple alors
là il pourrait surfer sur la vague donc
à mon avis il est quand même dans le
paysagement c'est l'homme politique le
plus impopulaire de France notamment sur
les très mauvaises opinions on sait que
le plus de rejets de rejet c'est l'homme
politique repoussoir c'est vrai que il a
quand même un moment très difficile à
vivre et la légitime de seront pas un
succès puis ce désert électoral après
mais comme Richard il a quand même une
opportunité c'est que cette double
séquence internationale pouvoir d'achat
où il a quasiment aucun espace où sa
voix ou l'émetteur est absolument
inaudible cesse ou recul et le retour de
thématique identitaire ou certes il se
rend compte avec la droite de LR et
Marine Le Pen mais il a effectivement
une force de persuasion qui pourrait le
remettre sur le devant de la scène merci
beaucoup monsieur d'être venu donc
débattre de la situation de l'extrême
droite sur ce plateau de savoard On
passe à présent à notre grand témoins du
jour et en cette avant veille de 1er mai
nous accueillons l'ancien secrétaire
général de Force Ouvrière Jean-Claude
Mahé il a connu quatre présidents
différents en tant que leader de de
Force Ouvrière dont Emmanuel Macron a
ses débuts ce ne sont là donc
quelques-unes des raisons pour
lesquelles on a décidé de l'inviter
Marco pommier
si on vous invite Jean-Claude Mahy c'est
parce que nous sommes entrés dans une
nouvelle ère paraît-il pour gouverner et
apaiser les colères Emmanuel Macron tout
juste réélu promet une nouvelle méthode
cette terre nouvelle ne sera pas la
continuité du quinquennat qui s'achève
mais l'invention collective d'une
méthode refondée pour 5 années de mieux
au service de notre pays Jean-Claude
Mailly vous êtes une figure de la lutte
syndicale ancien secrétaire général de
Force Ouvrière pendant 14 ans vous avez
vu défiler 11 ministres du travail cette
Premier ministre et quatre chefs de
l'État vous qui étiez en première ligne
dans les manifestations contre le
Contrat Première Embauche signé
Dominique de Villepin contre aussi la
loi travail de Myriam el khomri ou la
réforme ferroviaire d'un certain
Emmanuel Macron et à l'époque la méthode
ne vous plaisait pas ils annoncent un
programme les quatre ou cinq points et
après discute mais on a l'impression que
ça n'avance pas c'est de la méthode ça
justement c'est de la mauvaise méthode
c'est pas du vrai dialogue c'est pas de
la vraie discussion alors quelle méthode
pour le quinquennat Macron saison 2 car
les dossiers brûlants ne manquent pas
pouvoir d'achat crise de l'hôpital
système de retraite comment éviter
l'embrasement social comment rénover
aussi un dialogue social dégradé
affaibli alors que les salariés semblent
bouder leur représentants syndicaux et
pour relever ses défis que doit faire
Emmanuel Macron car après tout a-t-on
déjà vu le vainqueur d'une compétition
changer une méthode qui gagne à vos yeux
en tout cas il est trop déconnecté du
réels
bien entendu oui mais un peu déconnecté
de ce que vivent les gens et ça c'est
déconnecté de ce que vivent je connais
pas le terrain selon vous oui il y a pas
de culture sociale non plus mais ça
c'est pas le seul à ce niveau là mais en
tous les cas pas suffisamment entouré et
oui et déconnecté alors Jean-Claude
Mailly est avant veille du 1er mai jour
des travailleurs à l'heure aussi où
Laurent Berger patron de la CFDT réclame
un grand rendez-vous social cette
question le jupitérien Macron peut-il
vraiment changer à vous la parole
bonsoir Jean-Claude Mahy je vous pose la
question que Marco pommier vous pose
est-ce que vous y croyez vous un nouveau
Macron ça vous semble possible à Macron
moins Jupiter rien plus à l'écoute des
syndicats c'est souhaitables c'est
souhaitable maintenant il l'a promis un
peu au début de son quinquennat vous
étiez encore à la tête de Force Ouvrière
au début de son quinquennat sur les
ordonnances même si à des points
négatifs sur ces ordonnances il y avait
une vraie concertation à ça je maintiens
ça a duré tout l'été tous les jours et
que c'est pas forcément avec lui mais
avec le gouvernement alors vous entendez
quoi par concertation il a repris des
éléments proposés par les syndicats oui
je donne un seul exemple qui était pour
moi et mon organisation à l'époque très
important c'était le maintien de la
négociation au niveau des la grange
national voilà qui devait disparaître
normalement on a obtenu par un exemple
parmi d'autres on a obtenu que ce soit
maintenu donc vous savez la différence
entre une consultation et une
concertation consultation c'est souvent
de pure forme on vous demande votre avis
puis après on n'écoute rien quoi on
continue comme avant une concertation ça
veut dire que vous acceptez de discuter
vous acceptez de modifier
fonction de ce qu'on vous dit de
modifier votre position voir
d'abandonner des choses voilà c'est la
différence c'est ça c'est gâté dans la
suite du quinquennat et écoutez pendant
la campagne je pense que c'est quelqu'un
d'intelligent donc il a vu enfin pour
puis c'est pas compliqué de voir je veux
dire d'une certaine manière quand on
voit que plus de 50% des électeurs ont
voté pour des extrêmes au premier tour
que Marine Le Pen a près de 42% etc donc
qui a des fractures on appelle ça comme
on veut donc à un moment donné il l'a
dit lui-même à différentes reprises y
compris le soir de de sa victoire il l'a
redit faut réinventer il faut une
nouvelle méthode de dialogue etc on va
voir si cette promesse va être va être
par la suite et on va le recevoir
rapidement et qu'est-ce qui doit changer
selon vous dans sa méthode c'est ce qui
doit changer c'est que il avait une
tendance au fond de lui-même mais même
dans la première fois qu'il était
candidat une tendance au fond du même à
considérer que les syndicats grosso modo
c'est voilà ça fait perdre du temps
c'est des freins pour mes réformes moi
je veux aller dans intermédiaires
au-delà des syndicats
d'une certaine manière oui l'écorrates
ce qu'on appelle les corps
intermédiaires voilà ce sont ce sont des
freins des freins sa volonté d'aller
vite dans les réformes et puis que tout
ce qui était de caractère national
c'était du ressort de l'intérêt général
donc de l'État donc c'est les syndicats
leur place c'est dans l'entreprise
administration pas plus loin voilà donc
ça c'est ce qui pensait fondamentalement
je pense que au fil du temps il s'est
rendu compte que c'était plus compliqué
que on a vu avec les gilets jaunes c'est
bien quand il y a des problèmes de voir
discuter avec d'avoir des représentants
en face de soi qui le but c'était pas le
cas avec les gilets jaunes donc voilà
est-ce que fondamentalement c'est pas
simplement des promesses en l'air mais
qu'il va changer écoutez je pense qu'on
aura une réponse très rapidement quand
on aura le nouveau gouvernement le
secrétaire général de la CFDT Laurent
Berger a lancé un appel à Emmanuel
Macron cette semaine dans les colonnes
du monde j'imagine que vous avez lu
cette tribune monsieur le Président vous
ne pourrez pas relever ces défis tout
seul il appelle le chef de l'État a
considéré écouté et respecter les
Français et il lui demande de
co-construire ces décisions avec les
partenaires sociaux vous auriez pu
signer ce texte sur la co-construction
oui il y a longtemps que je pense qu'il
faut
on a historiquement on est
historiquement dans un pays où on a pour
des raisons diverses plus privilégiées
d'une certaine manière le conflit que la
négociation mais des deux côtés pour
vous y compris du côté de l'exécutif du
côté de l'exécutif à combien de fois
prenez la réformes des retraites
successives combien de fois un
gouvernement considérait qu'une bonne
réforme des retraites c'est une réforme
qui mettait des gens dans la rue mais
qui et qui infinie l'arrivait voilà j'ai
tenu j'ai le droit de d'afficher une
victoire politique
y compris de vis-à-vis des instances
européennes sur les questions de déficit
etc voilà alors qu'une pour moi une
bonne réforme une bonne réforme et on
verra dans les dans les semaines à venir
une bonne réforme c'est celle qui arrive
à par la discussion arriver à un
consentement non pas forcément général
mais quand même un consentement assez
c'est important de l'ensemble des
parties concernés à ce moment-là on peut
dire que c'est une bonne réforme donc
oui Laurent Berger là-dessus il a raison
de dire voilà vous tout seul on voit ce
qu'on vous faites tout seul on voit ce
que ça donne une fine certes vous êtes
élu c'est légitime il n'y a aucune
discussion pour moi là-dessus mais si
l'on veut pas se retrouver dans dans 5
ans avec une situation encore plus
difficile parce que quand même plus ça
va plus ça monte donc obligatoirement un
changement de méthode est nécessaire
nonobstant les questions de fond on va
se pencher aussi du côté des syndicats
si vous le voulez bien parce que
Emmanuel Macron a annoncé donc plusieurs
concertations sur les retraites sur
l'école mais regardez ce qu'on dit
Philippe Martin précédent l'humanité
magazine de cette semaine il n'y aura
pas d'état de grâce je ne comprends pas
comment Emmanuel Macron espère nous
refaire le coup de la concertation on a
assez usé notre salive et il ajoute plus
loin le rapport de force ça reste une
valeur sûre ça donne le ton est-ce que
vous regrettez justement la tonalité de
ses propos
les ce qu'il veut moi je me souviens de
prendre la concertation qui a été sur
les ordonnances assez longues etc on n'a
pas beaucoup entendu la CGT à l'époque
au moins dans les concertations bon
après le rapport de force la négociation
c'est un rapport de force l'objectif de
rapport de force c'est pas forcément
être dans la rue et faire grève le
rapport de force c'est on n'a pas les
mêmes intérêts on essaie de discuter de
voir quel est le compromis ça veut dire
vous savez vous prenez ces sœurs
disaient c'est quoi un bon accord c'est
quand le syndicat considère qu'il aurait
pu obtenir plus et que du côté de
l'employeur ou de l'État on considère
qu'on a trop lâché bah là on peut
considérer qu'on arrive qu'on arrive à
un bon accord donc le conflit c'est
enfin le conflit pour le conflit je vois
pas bien l'intérêt quoi mais en même
temps avant une concertation sur le
report de l'âge légal de la retraite on
imagine que à l'Élysée on va regarder de
près combien de personnes seront dans
les défilés du 1er mai s'il commence ça
fait partie du rapport de force non pour
moi ça ça fait partie de l'ancienne
méthode ou de la méthode qui a été
utilisé par les gouvernements successifs
c'est pas ça la bonne méthode sur un
dossier comme les retraites d'abord on
sait pas grand chose sauf pour le moment
65 ans ou 64 je sais pas bon 65 ans et
on 100 euros minimum on sait rien de
plus si demain le gouvernement décide de
mettre ce dossier sur la table ça veut
dire voilà nous ce que on envisage quel
est votre position les uns et les autres
et après ils bougent son dossier voir il
l'abandonne s'il considère que c'est pas
bon mais c'est pas de dire on va voir
combien il y a de monde dans la rue on
va voir combien on discute alors ça sera
peut-être ça ça veut dire que la méthode
n'aura pas changé si on veut rentrer
dans une logique qui est logique de
discussion de négociation il faut tout
mettre sur la table après un moment
donné ça veut pas dire qu'à la fin on
est d'accord mais au moins on discute à
fond et on ne cache rien est-ce que par
exemple première question c'est est-ce
que l'objectif des 65 ans qui pour moi
ne passe pas c'est clair bon
c'est un peu après c'est le dossier des
retraites c'est un dossier avec plein de
tiroirs donc mais est-ce pourquoi 65 ans
est-ce que c'est une question
d'équilibre financier des retraites à
long terme pas évident si on regarde les
rapports des uns des autres ou est-ce
que c'est pour dégager 16 milliards
d'euros pour se mettre en conformité
avec bruit financier les engagements
pour financer l'autonomie oui mais
l'autonomie attendez il faut financer la
question de dépendance c'est évident
mais au finance pas ça avec la retraite
vous prenez pas d'un côté pour mettre de
l'autre et ça veut dire quoi est-ce que
ça veut pas dire que quelque part il s'y
prend mal que cette réforme des
retraites c'est pas la réforme à faire
maintenant je pense pas qu'il y ait
urgence la seule urgence pour les
retraites c'est de présenter vous savez
que la France normalement c'était pas
demain 30 avril il aurait fallu
présenter bon l'élection a changé la
donne mais sur le timing il faut les
présenter notre programme tri annuel à
Bruxelles sur
économique la maîtrise des déficites etc
bon ça a été en même temps on est dans
une période jusqu'à la fin de l'année
les 3% ont été suspendus etc bah ouais
mais quelle est la trajectoire de la
France donc c'est dans c'est aussi dans
ce cadre là que ça 65 ans donc on
démarre pas un dossier sur les retraites
pour des critères uniquement financiers
donc faut tout mettre sur la table parce
que quand après quand on regarde bien
les choses quand si on change rien sur
les critères etc quelqu'un qui est né en
1973 avec les règles actuelles qui a
commencé à bosser à 21 ans c'est à peu
près l'âge moyen 21 22 aujourd'hui
disons 21
+ 43 années de cotisation ça veut dire
qu'il peut partir à taux plein dans les
règles actuelles à 64 ans donc par
contre la France a été victime de la
double peine on a choisi la double peine
à la fois on a allongé l'âge reculer
l'âge moins qu'ailleurs c'est vrai mais
on a beaucoup plus augmenté la durée de
recotisations voilà mais ça fait ça par
exemple c'est un exemple parmi d'autres
des discussions qu'on devrait avoir mais
pour ça il faut accepter de se mettre
autour de la table il faut pas faire ça
à la va vite il faut prendre le temps de
discuter et après on fait le point on va
parler du climat social en France
aujourd'hui qui est vraiment explosif la
présidentielle a marqué une fracture
électorale entre deux France si on
schématise un peu d'un côté il y a la
France qui va bien qui vote Emmanuel
Macron qui profite de la mondialisation
et puis la France qui va mal qui vote
Marine Le Pen est-ce que dans ce
contexte explosif le syndicalisme
réformiste à sa place en France est-ce
qu'il peut se faire entendre des
Français en colère la difficulté oui moi
je pense que oui mais la difficulté pour
syndicalisme ou pour les organisations
informées il y en a plusieurs en France
c'est quand vous êtes dans une logique
de syndicalisme il vous faut des
interlocuteurs parce que le moyen
privilégié pour un syndicat réformiste
c'est la négociation c'est de trouver
une solution si on part du principe que
vous avez un interlocuteur que vous
pouvez négocier est-ce que le résultat
d'une négociation les syndicats
réformistes seront capables de les faire
accepter à leur base moi je pense que
oui écoutez quand vous regardez
l'histoire des retraites alors sur les
retraites complémentaires qui relèvent
de la responsabilité des interlocuteurs
sociaux depuis la prière en fait
quand vous regardez ça on a toujours
géré de manière responsable et ça jamais
fait de vagues y compris quand c'était
difficile la question des retraites
complémentaires donc ça veut dire que
contient un engagement peut-être pas un
mais moi écoutez moi dans mon histoire
syndicale aujourd'hui j'ai pu je parle
plus au nom de FO j'ai plus de mandat
faux mais dans mon histoire syndicale
j'ai toujours remarqué au moins ces 15
c'est 15 20 dernières années quand vous
prenez une négociation nationale ou un
point important à discuter avec le
gouvernement si vous avez au moins deux
des trois grandes organisations qui sont
d'accord ça passe et en général c'était
qui au niveau national c'est pas la CGT
c'était faux et la CFDT quand elles
étaient d'accord ça passait ça discutait
ça passait donc moi je pense que oui le
syndicalisme réformiste à sa place à
condition d'avoir en face des
interlocuteurs qui acceptent de discuter
toujours dans cette tribune de Laurent
bergeri il souligne à un moment
attention les gens qui ont voté pour
vous monsieur Macron ils ont pas
forcément voté pour vos idées est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron vous semble suffisamment
par cette présidentielle pour engager
une réforme des retraites qui reportent
l'âge légal à 65 ans
c'est vrai que une partie des électeurs
qui ont voté Laurent Berger contestent
pas du tout la légitimité de d'Emmanuel
Macron mais il pose quand même cette
question là si on comptait ça enfin
aux États-Unis quoi je veux dire faut
arrêter on peut avoir des Trump en
France c'est pas la question mais bon il
est élu légitimement etc le problème
maintenant c'est pour que la politique
qu'il veuille mener s'il veut marquer
l'histoire c'est pas en fracturant plus
la France c'est de le dit d'ailleurs
dans ce discours après on verra dans la
réalité c'est de d'apaiser c'est de
Réconc c'est de réconcilier réconcilier
le pays donc ça veut dire du changement
de méthode ça veut dire bon d'être il
sait changer si regardez bien pendant la
crise sanitaire il est passé d'une
conception très libérale de l'économie
ou quoi qu'il en coûte peut pas dire que
c'est libéral bon donc il sait changer
est-ce qu'il pas accepter là non
concrètement dans les semaines à venir
de changer moi je pense que c'est c'est
indispensable mais oui mais ça peut se
faire voilà c'est possible c'est une
question de volonté vous avez le
sentiment que cette présidentielle elle
a permis de purger toutes les colères et
les frustrations qu'il y a dans la
société non non ça vous inquiète oui oui
parce que on va voir comment les choses
tournent en plus on est quand même dans
un contexte général qui est quand même
pas simple entre la guerre en Ukraine
les difficultés en Chine avec
la stratégie zéro covid
les approvisionnements composants par
exemple qui qui se casse la figure on
est en train de rentrer dans une période
de stagnation ça veut dire une période
de croissance ou de récession plus
d'une croissance à 0% au premier
trimestre et une inflation sur 12 mois
4,8% il y a une question pouvoir d'achat
central une question salaire est-ce que
c'est ça qui peut résoudre la colère des
Français des éléments oui je pense que
oui oui c'est bien quand vous avez une
inflation qui grimpe on n'a pas connu je
vous rappelle que 48 je crois que la
dernière fois c'était en 85 ça fait
quelques quelques années quand même bon
donc quand d'abord il faut justement des
salaires c'est on voit bien que le SMIC
va devoir augmenter de 2,65 moi je pense
qu'il faut faire un petit coup de pouce
je dis pas 10 %. mais il faut il faut
soutenir on peut pas multiplier à
l'infini l'échec ceci les chèques cela
et cetera même si on peut faire des
actions ciblées à un moment donné la
question du pouvoir d'achat elle est
posée alors à la fois sur le salaire
minimum mais aussi il faut pousser les
employeurs à négocier au niveau des
branches sur les minimum conventionnels
merci Jean-Claude Mahy vous restez avec
nous on accueille nos affranchis du jour
avec Vincent Huger grand reporter qui va
nous parler de la Transnistrie et
Brandon warrett journaliste passionné
d'histoire qui va d'ailleurs nous
rafraîchir un peu la mémoire si l'on
peut dire sur les trois cohabitations
que la France a connu sous la Cinquième
République on va commencer avec Vincent
Hugo qui rentre à l'instant qui et qui
et qui s'installe bonsoir Vincent alors
ce soir focus sur un tout petit pays qui
pourrait bien jouer un rôle crucial dans
la guerre en Ukraine et oui parce qu'aux
yeux de l'amateur de BTV vintage la
Transnistrie pourrait figurer sur la
carte des aventures de Tintin entre
s'ils avis et Bordurie ses pays
imaginaires parcourus par le petit
reporter plus illustre d'ailleurs pour
ça houpette que pour ses papiers
puisqu'il n'en a jamais écrit aucun
mauvaise pioche puisque la Transnistrie
existe bel et bien elle a surgi des
brumes géopolitiques à la faveur si
j'ose dire de l'agression russe cette
principauté soviéto mafieuse coincée
entre le flanc ouest de l'Ukraine et la
fragile Moldavie et bien le coche
pourtant toutes les cases de la fiction
née dans l'esprit d'un scénariste rotor
voyez déjà sa forme ses contours pour le
moins insolite une longue et étroite
langue de terre est tirée sur 450 km
puis à son statut ensuite celui de
république séparatiste autoproclamé
jaillit voilà trois décennies sur les
décombres de la défunt URSS alors ce qui
peut surprendre c'est que bien que la
soit un peu inféodée on va dire au
Kremlin peuplée majoritairement de
ruissofun ça n'a pas été reconnue par
Moscou et ce n'est pas faute d'y mettre
du sien pourtant la sinistre
Transnistrie ressemble à si méprendre à
un musée vivant de la grandeur
soviétique témoin son drapeau rouge et
vert frappé du trio légendaire il faut
aussi marteau étoile une statue de
Lénine trône au cœur de tira spol la
capitale est un buste du père de la
révolution bolchevique montre la garde
devant sa mairie pardon pardon pas ça
mairie devant la maison des Soviets
puisque tel et son nom Tintin si tu nous
entends amour face sur la gouvernance
très singulière de cet enclave
sécessionniste moldave paradis des
trafiquants de tout poil armes drogue
être humain tout passe et tout y passe
au besoin via le port ukrainien d'Odessa
mais la région n'en est plus à un
paradoxe près un conglomératisé Cherif
on a les Far West qu'on peut règne sur
l'économie locale alors doit d'où
vient-il et qu'on contrôle-t-il
réellement en Transnistrie et bien fondé
par vétérans des services de sécurité de
l’air soviétique il contrôle le BTP la
banque les télécoms le textile les
supermarchés les stations services si
ton C3 fleurons une distillerie de
Cognac fameuse un élevage d'esturgeon
béluga par ici caviar et un club de foot
le shérif tira Paul lequel s'est offert
le luxe en septembre dernier de
terrasser le Real Madrid dans son entre
mythique de Santiago Bernabéu
tout cela pourrait sembler exotique si
l'on entendait pas tonner les tambours
de la guerre objection recevable votre
honneur trèfle d'ironie facile car il
n'y a pas de quoi rire pour le
paramoscovite qui lui fournit
gracieusement son gaz et maintient sur
place un contingent de 1500 soldats mais
aussi quelques dépôts de munitions XXL
la Transnistrie s'apparente à une tête
de pont idéal qu'il s'agisse d'étouffer
l'Ukraine méridionale ou de saper
l'assise d'une Moldavie résolument
tourné vers l'Europe à l'instar de sa
présidente Maya sandou un éminent
général russe a dénoncé voilà peu
l'oppression dans ce rêve victime dans
la communauté procremlin soit omoprêt le
prétexte invoqué hier pour annexer la
Crimée ou investir le don de basse
aujourd'hui pour envahir l'Ukraine même
motif même punition disons que sans
céder à la transc sinistrose il y a tout
lieu de le craindre nous avons commencé
avec Hergé finissons avec lui après
d'autres cette hypothèque là n'a pas
fini d'assombrir l'horizon un peu si
vous voulez à l'image du sparadrap du
capitaine Haddock ce genre de truc qui
colle à la peau et dont on entend 20
milles sabords de se débarrasser mille
sabords et au moins autant de carnage à
venir Merci à VOUS Vincent Huger on
passe à vous Brandon après les résultats
du second tour de la de la
présidentielle l'hypothèse d'une
nouvelle cohabitation resurgit et c'est
pas inédit en France oui puisque la
cohabitation est envisagée dès 1967 tant
les résultats attendus par le général de
Gaulle aux législatif du mois de mars
paraissait incertain elle est finalement
instaurée pour la première fois près de
20 ans plus tard en 1986 et cette fois
c'était pas une surprise mais la
majorité socialiste avec Mitterrand et
suit échec un échec européenne cantonal
alors forcément à droite c'est comme si
c'était déjà fait Jacques Chirac est à
l'époque le président du RPR ne va pas
jusqu'à s'afficher en Chirac Premier
ministre comme le fait en ce moment
Jean-Luc Mélenchon mais regardez cette
affiche de campagne pour les
législatives de 1986 on voit Jacques
Chirac au milieu avec ses copains avec
cette énorme slogan avec une équipe
voilà exactement JP on voit aussi
François Fillon vivement demain ce
slogan qui est très énorme vivement
demain qu'on entre au gouvernement c'est
un peu ça l'idée finalement un Mélenchon
n'a rien inventé c'est juste inspiré des
idées du RPR et donc à ce moment là
Jacques Chirac devient premier ministre
et les Français découvrent la
cohabitation mais c'est une conjoncture
politique totalement inédite dans
l'histoire de la République un président
de gauche avec un premier ministre de
droite et le 22 mars 1986 regardez ces
images un s'ouvre le tout premier
Conseil des Ministres de la cohabitation
le ton est donné avec une ambiance
glaciale le président Mitterrand est
isolé face à son chef du gouvernement et
ses 36 ministres il y aura d'ailleurs
pas de traditionnel photo de famille de
déclaration à la presse et à la sortie
du palais ça c'est très intéressant
regardez c'est sourire qui en disent
long notamment on va le voir juste après
celui de Charles Pasqua voilà on voit le
Premier ministre c'est très une ambiance
très tendue et donc on a un sourire de
Charles Pasqua qui a l'air très moqueur
il va il va sortir juste là c'est
symptomatique justement à ce moment-là
du peu de respect qu'il y a entre entre
lui et le président de la République
alors dans cette cohabitation il a fallu
inventer des règles et c'est un peu
François Mitterrand qui s'est collé il
n'est pas question pour Mitterrand en
tout cas d'inaugurer les chrysanthèmes
comme le disait Georges Clémenceau pour
qualifier le rôle du président sous la
Troisième République non non il a il
faisait déjà une mise une mise au point
plusieurs mois avant les élections
législatives écoutez-le
alors tous ceux qui parlent parce qu'ils
ont un gros appétit ce précipitent vers
ce qu'il croit être un fromage je leur
dis c'est pas la peine de s'expliquer
davantage c'est non la clé sous le
paillasson vous ne connaissez pas c'est
pas moi genre pendant des ans Mitterrand
va se forger une image de défenseur
contre les décisions gouvernementales
surtout lorsqu'elles entraînent une
hostilité en de l'opinion publique il va
multiplier aussi les signes en direction
des futurs électeurs notamment fin 1986
avec la grande manifestation étudiante
contre le projet de de réforme de
l'enseignement supérieur à ce moment-là
Mitterrand est au zénith de sa
popularité encore plus notamment lors du
débat de l'entre-deux-tours de
l'élection présidentielle de 1988 on le
voit avec une assurance qui contraste
forcément avec l'agitation à du Premier
ministre sortant écoutez-les ces
cultissimes ce soir
je ne suis pas le premier ministre et
vous n'êtes pas le président de la
République nous sommes deux candidats à
égalité et qui se soumettent au jugement
des Français
seuls
Mitterrand
Monsieur le Premier Ministre
redoutable réplique de François
Mitterrand en 1993 c'est une vague bleue
qui déferle sur les législatives sur le
Parlement mais la saison 2 de la
cohabitation débarque dans le paysage
politique français Édouard Balladur
devient le nouveau Premier ministre et
la cohabitation change de ton elle
devient plus apaisée pour deux raisons
François Mitterrand est très affaibli
politiquement le Parti socialiste ne
récolte que 57 sièges au législatives et
affaibli physiquement vu qu'en 1981 on
lui a diagnostiqué un cancer de la
prostate en 1992 les Français seront au
courant donc forcément il affirme ne pas
briguer un troisième mandat et le 2
avril 1993 bis repetita s'ouvre le
premier Conseil des Ministres de la
deuxième cohabitation on le voit ici on
retrouve Mitterrand on retrouve Balladur
mais cette fois-ci par rapport à 1986 il
a changé de face il est plus ministre de
l'Économie des Finances on trouve
toujours une crise passion du côté de
Mitterrand et toujours ce sourire
moqueur de la part de Charles Pasqua et
en 90 7 c'est reparti pour une troisième
cohabitation vous avez aimé ou détester
la saison 2 alors on vous offre la
saison 3 cette nouvelle cohabitation
s'ouvre dans un contexte par contre là
encore plus différent que les deux
autres dans la mesure où elle n'était
pas du tout attendue elle est en vient à
l'issue d'un pari totalement surprenant
de la part du président Chirac et il dit
sous l'assemblée à ce moment-là donc
c'est une phrase assez choc et voilà
comment se tirer une balle dans le pied
alors qu'il pensait ressortir des
législatives avec une majorité encore
plus confortable la gauche remporte les
élections Lionel Jospin est nommé
Premier ministre il le restera jusqu'à
la fin du septainer en 2002 et trois
covitations donc les Français se sont
habitués à un partage du pouvoir merci
beaucoup Brandon Noiret cette émission
touchait à sa fin merci à tous les trois
d'être venu sur le plateau de LCP tout
de suite votre soirée documentaire avec
Happy la dictature du bonheur sur sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est avec Valérie
Brochard et des collégiens de 3e dans
cette zone d'éducation prioritaire
passez une bonne soirée sur LCP
[Musique]